hey guys this is Vadim with max sec and
this is the brand new Galaxy Note tend
to day we're going to be comparing it to
the galaxy s 10 plus we're gonna compare
all of the little differences and we're
gonna see which one you should buy and
we're also going to take a look at if
it's worth upgrading from the galaxy s
10 plus to the note 10 plus so let's go
ahead and unbox this phone so I got the
phone right here in my hand but before I
peel off the sticker and take a look at
the phone I want to quickly mention that
you do get a faster 25 watt charger and
it's actually USB see right here instead
of USB a on the charger that comes with
the SN Plus which is only 15 watts
compared to 25 right here so even though
the battery is larger on the note 10
it's 4300 instead of 4100 it's still
gonna be charging it quicker so that's
really nice all right let's get this
sticker off just like that Wow
well it's surprisingly reflective it's
almost like a mirror but like this
finish is very interesting because it
like reflects the light and all these
different colors at the same time and
comparing it to this one I don't know to
be honest I kind of like the S 10 Plus
finish because like I feel like the note
10 plus with its like rainbow colors
it's a bit flashy maybe it's a little
bit too flashy for me at least in my
opinion and I'm also seeing that these
little logos right here you're getting
like the galaxy s 10 plus and all this
little manufacturer information it gets
cut down significantly on the bottom of
the note 10 plus so it's definitely a
much cleaner look compared to the s10
plus one of the differences I see
instantly is obviously the much larger
size it's definitely wider its taller
you guys can see that right there it's
just like a brick it's just so huge and
this foam is already a pretty big foam
and another difference is it's so much
more boxy like these corners here
definitely like stick out compared to
the nice rounded corners of the s10 plus
so I definitely prefer the SN Plus in
its rounded design compared to this more
Boxey look and going to the bottom it
looks fairly similar everything's laid
out pretty much the same except you no
longer get a headphone jack on the note
10 plus samsung was like marketing that
for a while but now it's gone but there
you go if you really need a headphone
jack the SN plus is already gonna be a
much better choice for you one thing I
really loved about the s10 plus was this
horizontal layout of the camera lenses
it's really nice symmetrical it all fits
into one little unit whereas before you
would get that little fingerprint sensor
on the back that would really just mess
up the whole layout and it looks really
clean and I really like this look but on
the note 10 plus honestly I love the
vertical layout with these three sensors
it all just looks so nice looking at the
size they both look pretty similar in
thickness and one thing that I'm
instantly noticing is that the frame is
super thin on the note 10 plus compared
to the sm plus maybe three times thinner
and it actually is offset towards the
front of the phone which is very
interesting so the back glass kind of
wraps around and circles around more
than on the s10 plus now on the other
side we've got these buttons on the note
10 plus and it's interesting because the
frame actually goes up and wraps around
the button so it gets thicker around the
buttons and it goes back to a very thin
frame along with that the power button
now doubles as the Bigsby button whereas
on the SN plus you actually had a
dedicated button for that which a lot of
people would accidentally press and it
would be really annoying so I'm really
glad they made that choice before
compare displays and speaker quality I
want to quickly mention that whichever
phone you choose you should definitely
consider buying a warranty from our
sponsor for this video up see up see
works with nationwide certified repair
shops and helps buyers in the United
States save up to 70% on a warranty
compared to retailers and you can
purchase it within 45 days after your
smart phone purchase upsie makes it
incredibly easy to make a claim by
having real people available on the
phone 24/7 365 days a year and they
store your receipt all the info you'll
need right in your UPSI account you can
use a link in the video description with
the code max tech today for 10% off your
first warranty purchase I'm setting up
the phone right now and one thing I'm
noticing
is that the ultrasonic fingerprint
scanner is actually higher up on the
phone compared to the s10 plus so this
was a little bit annoying on the s10
plus because it wasn't really
comfortable to reach your thumb down
there so I think this is a much more
convenient location so I'm glad that
Samsung did this now getting to the
display is one thing I'm noticing on the
note 10 plus is that the curve on both
edges starts a lot later and closer to
the side so it seems like it's going to
prevent accidental touches a lot better
than the s10 plus another thing I notice
on the note 10 plus is that the bezels
are a lot thinner compared to the s10
plus specifically at the top and the
bottom and the reason for that is that
the speaker grille is now incredibly
thin right up against the frame compared
to the s10 plus which has quite a bit
bigger speaker grille right there at the
top and looking at these hole punches
the note ends is smaller because it only
has a single camera compared to dual
cameras on the s10 plus but it is right
there in the center so it's kind of
distracting compared to the s10 that has
it in the corner so I personally prefer
the look of the s10 kind of further away
especially if you have it in landscape
mode the center hole punch is definitely
more distracting on the note 10 plus so
both of these phones actually have
literally identical displays the quality
is the same the colors are the same the
brightness is literally the same you can
see it right here so there are no
differences in display quality so
because the top speaker on the note 10
plus is so much thinner than the one on
the s10 plus we're gonna go ahead and do
a sound comparison on YouTube and test
out the speakers so we've got Dolby
Atmos turned on on auto mode on both of
these phones so let's go ahead and start
with you know it's an plus
[Music]
sounds pretty good next one
[Music]
okay interesting back to the no 10
[Music]
right so I'm definitely noticing much
brighter highs on the s10 plus compared
to the note 10 plus this seems a little
bit kind of dull or faded out it's
definitely just as loud they both really
loud volume wise but the sm+ does have a
wider soundstage and much brighter highs
so that's I guess a downside with the
note 10 Plus which I didn't really
expect now let's talk about the cameras
we're getting the exact same triple-n
setup as the s10 plus the lenses are
literally identical same megapixels same
everything except there's a couple of
changes with these sensors the sn+ had a
heartbeat sensor right here which is
gone on the note 10 plus but it replaces
it with a 3d scanner which you can use
to scan 3d objects or you can actually
use it with a brand new mode called life
a focus video we're gonna test that out
right now all right so how's it working
do you see blur behind me there's a lot
of color oh around you and at the edges
of your body okay cool so how is the
blur edging like you see my ears or are
they blurred out as well they're pretty
blurred out so I just watched that clip
and I notice a couple of interesting
things the blur on the outside
definitely looks really cool compared to
a regular video but one thing like my
ears were blurred out and around my body
was blurred out is it was a little bit
weird it wasn't perfect so it seems like
you wouldn't use this all the time and
interestingly you also get live focus
video for the front-facing camera but
the weird thing is the essence actually
has an extra camera lens right there on
the front but you don't get life focused
video mode so it's definitely seems like
a software-only feature which is lacking
on the s10 plus and another difference
is that the no 10 plus gets a special
night mode on the selfie camera which
you do not get on the s10 so we're
definitely gonna be testing that out and
we're gonna put that information into
the full review of this phone so if
you're not already subscribed make sure
to do that right now before I talk about
the s-pen and give my final conclusions
I want to first mention that both of
these phones are packing the Snapdragon
processors which are literally identical
like I'm
and Geekbench for i don't know if you
guys can see this but all of the cpu
cores and all the clock speeds are
literally identical on both of these
phones the test is done and you can see
that both full has got exactly the same
score so there's no difference at all in
processor performance now interesting
the note 10 plus does get 12 gigabytes
of RAM compared to only 8 on the s10
plus but you can get 12 on this phone if
you buy one of the higher-end models I
think it's the 1 terabyte model but the
note 10 plus comes with 12 gigs of RAM
on any model that you buy and finally
let's check out the s-pen all right so
first impressions looks pretty nice I
like the color and interestingly it does
feel a little bit too light in flimsy
like it's made out of all plastic this
is plastic this is plastic I think the
only piece of metal here is this and
that's because it's touching the bottom
of the phone it's got to be metal pretty
sure it's metal yeah but it does feel a
little bit flimsy I don't really like
how it feels I wish it was a little bit
heavier
you know the s-pen does have a lot of
new features which I'm sure are great
and I'm gonna be testing them out a lot
more but I feel like the gesture
controls and all that kind of stuff I
feel like it's a bit gimmicky
I feel like business people might use it
more for like signing documents and
doing stuff like that but for the
regular person I don't know if you
really need this s-pen so with all that
out of the way after testing and
comparing these two I honestly feel like
the note 10 plus is still a little bit
underwhelming especially for the price
tag of $1,100 now with the SM plus you
can probably find this for around six
hundred fifty seven hundred fifty
dollars on Amazon and when you think
about that difference it's actually a
lot of cash to pay for the note 10 plus
and in reality is it worth upgrading I
don't think it's worth operating at all
and even if you're buying a brand new
phone you don't have either of these I
think the S 10 plus is the better choice
because you really don't get that much
more with an O 10 plus so thank you guys
for watching I hope you enjoy this
comparison if you have any comments or
concerns definitely leave a comment down
below and if you're not already
subscribed click that button above and
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video